[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
okay so I've been working on a really
exciting project and I can't really talk
about it yet but this past summer I
headed off to New York for three nights
with add the family to get it done as
always I was like a mixed bag of
emotions before going away super excited
about the opportunity but also juggling
major mom and wife Guild I was also
mostly anxious about not sleeping and
then having to work really super long
days while having to be on so my
insomnia leading up to going away was
horrible which basically always happens
before a really important day basically
what happens is I obsess over sleeping
really well so that you know I don't get
sick and I have the energy to perform
well but that Obsession just kind of
makes sleep virtually impossible
self-sabotage at its finest but as they
say the show must go on and your girl
knows how to Rally now before we get too
far into this I want to pull up my
general disclaimer to including a
reminder that the meals you see me eat
here are just kind of random examples
and not necessarily how I eat every
single day my sheer focus on this trip
was to nourish my body even though I was
often too tired and also kind of like
too anxious to eat I also honestly ended
up eating like more raw vegetables and
salads than I normally would at home
when I can kind of cook hot meals
because that was just what was readily
available to me on set and my focus was
on keeping my digestion regular and my
sleep and energy in decent shape so
please do not use these meals as a
prescription of what you should eat all
right let's get into the Vlog I'm just
gonna hop in here for a hot minute and
tell you about today's sponsor
established titles okay so I've always
had very lofty goals for myself but I
don't think I would have ever had
imagined that I would be a lady of
Scotland but here we are I somehow kind
of got jipped out of the Burly Scottish
man husband situation but maybe for the
better like I've already got a whole
house full of boys but this is probably
one of the coolest sponsorships I've
ever received so basically established
titles allows you to buy a title pack
with as little as one square foot of
dedicated land with a unique plot Number
and in exchange they will plant a tree
to help preserve the beautiful natural
Woodlands of Scotland so you get named a
Lorna Lady of Scotland based on the
historic Scottish tradition and
established titles will work with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help support
Global reforestation efforts this makes
a fantastic holiday gift for the person
who's just like impossible to buy for
and it also makes for like a really fun
conversation starter when you bust out
your credit card or your plane ticket or
your Facebook profile with the word Lord
or lady on it yes you can actually do
that no shame you become a legit
landowner so you can totally brag about
so if you want to get in on the Lord or
lady titles yourself and help preserve
wood conservation efforts check out my
link below the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my link
will get to be placed right next to my
plot we can totally build our own little
Abby's kitchen Kingdom if we get enough
of you guys to join Comey neighbors with
me I swear I throw like the best holiday
parties every year alright Lords and
Ladies back to the video so just trying
to get myself organized to go today
um just walked e to his Camp did not
want to go he cried did not want me to
leave will not probably want to play
today
um but yeah that's what I'm dealing with
right now but I got me my ass coffee
I'm just trying to like deal with the
show that is my work situation
um there's always like last minute
things that have to be changed that have
to be done there's so many moving parts
and I do have such an amazing team but
it means like coordinating with so many
different people and through different
people
um and it just like sometimes really
stresses me out I would love to just
like shut my eyes and let everything
happen around me but I'm not Kim
Kardashian so I don't I'm not sure I'm
I'm at that point yet but one day let's
hope let's hope for one day before I
burn out ideally
um
but at this point I feel like what I'm
most excited slash anxious about is not
sleeping tonight and I have to say like
I've been working up to this for the
past week kind of like practicing
um speaking to my psychiatrist every few
days giving him feedback on what I did
what worked what didn't work and I'm
gonna like give it my
all tonight and by that I mean I'm gonna
take a lot of drugs
um thankfully my call time is not that
early it seems like it might be early
for like most the crew because it's like
eight eight thirty but my my agent
Michelle was just like oh yeah that's
like lunch time for Abby that's that
should not be a problem and that's true
I'll have well I've gotten a lot done
before they need me in studio
um yeah I'm still so anxious of just
like me thinking oh my gosh what if I
don't sleep tonight
um I'm gonna have low energy what if I
lose my voice because that sometimes
happens it's a long day of filming it's
a long day of talking and you know it's
not just like me shooting a YouTube
video here at home where if I'm not
feeling it or whatever like it's just it
doesn't take me that long to get through
one and then I could take a break and or
I can just do one and then move on to
some other kind of work if I'm just not
feeling energetic enough
um but I'm just praying I'm I'm not
religious I'm literally going to pray
tonight pray to the Sleep gods that they
will just allow me to relax allow me to
unwind and not worry about sleep because
I'm not worried about the shoot I'm
gonna have a blast I cannot wait this is
my this is my dream This Is My Jam I'm
just worried about not sleeping that my
friends is how insomnia Falls with you
so even with all the drugs drugs upon
drugs piles above trials trials piles of
drugs and drugs for the other drugs and
the drugs to supplement the other drugs
that stop working
sometimes when the old Noggin can't shut
the [ __ ] up they don't work they don't
work and they leave you feeling super
drowsy and like lethargic and kind of
dizzy the next day so then you take the
coffee to counteract the effects of the
drugs and it just like uppers downers
uppers downers like wow this is what my
life has come to and I'm only 34.
but you guys know I'm working on it and
I hope that at least I have some fun in
New York I don't have a lot of time to
shop but you know me I'll get her done
get her done
all right back to getting stuff together
he had a good cry when I tried to leave
so
really breaks my mama heart
you can't see but I'm frowning
all right we have arrived so the first
thing I did was of course wash the [ __ ]
out of my hands and I changed my clothes
because I never want to wear airplane
clothes when I'm not on an airplane
um and just checking out this cute
little hotel one thing to note is that
the blackout blind situation she's not
gonna cut it for me so I might need to
make a beeline to like a CVS or
Walgreens to try to get some like black
garbage bags to throw on there like I am
a baby just learning how to sleep
because basically that's what I am but
yeah I'm gonna go for a quick little
walk
um it's so hot so beautiful outside and
I promised the kids I would buy them a
souvenir and this is really my only
chance to do that so let's do it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
apologize for the super terrible
lighting it's definitely not flattering
um but I want to show you what I got
before I deal with this whole blackout
blind situation so I bought too much I
got a rotisserie chicken which came with
broccoli rabe and cauliflower got a
spring mix salad with lots of cheese and
a beautiful piece of Focaccia which oh
my gosh so good and I found this kind of
skier yogurt which sounded super
interesting so I grabbed that and also
lots of fruit for snacking again the
plastic forks not my vibe
thank you
okay so the lighting situation is not
terrible but
like it's still giving me major anxiety
so I'm gonna try to make it better my
urine Insomniac without saying you're an
insomnia
[Music]
masterpiece
foreign
oh my God how much trouble am I gonna
get in for that bedtime snack here
I'm making myself
a cup of
protein oatmeal with some protein powder
in it it's pretty sad
it does not look good
but
I feel like it's going to help keep me
full overnight which is what I like well
it wasn't the best sleep but it wasn't
the worst sleep so I'm trying not to
like be disappointed because we did the
best that we could but
um the real problem wasn't even my
anxiety it was the fact this bed was so
hard and lumpy and the pillow was not
the right kind of pillow for me and I
realized all of this is like super
demanding Talent excuses but I have
never had to complain about a bed being
too hard before pillows yes I'm picking
but never never have I had a bed hurt me
so now my like whole shoulder and upper
back and neck is just like on fire
literally on fire and I need my husband
to help me but he's not here so I'm
gonna have to enlist some poor PA that
at the shoot this morning to give me a
rub down I've been laying here and like
the pain is distracting so I'm like
what's the point wasting time wasting
making it worse probably oh I'm getting
old I'm getting old this is the sign
um so I think what I'm going to do now
is get myself ready for the day
um they've got a little gym downstairs
so I might just do like let's see if I
can foam roll it a little bit and get a
coffee as soon as there's a Starbucks
that is open
let's hope it's an easy day
[Music]
thank you
okay call me a total Visa but
my neck is still like
so sore so I ran down the street to one
of the other hotels that were on my
original list this one's called the
James and I asked if they had
availability and they do and I'm just
gonna try out this bed and oh my gosh
can I get a do-over for last night and
just go to bed now yeah this is much
better and check this out that is what I
call a blackout blind situation yeah
okay sold sold now I just gotta move all
my over here
let's do it all right I just walked with
three huge bags including my children's
toys
um for like a good 20 minutes of a
schlep but I made it back here I've got
a few minutes to spare before I have to
get my booty over to the studio
um but I feel like this is a much better
space for me and and I know that I'm
super privileged to be able to just kind
of like switch up hotels on the Fly
um but I will say that you know if it's
impacting my sleep if it's impacting my
health because I'm in pain I'm not 20
years old anymore I cannot rally like I
used to so it is just worth the upgrade
and that's where I'm at in my life right
now but I'm excited for today
[Music]
clearly it's like like everyone's just
probably waking up now I feel like I've
done a whole day already so I'm I'm
ready for my second coffee okay so a
little light uh brekkie here in addition
to my coffee and my latte got some
banana bread I'm gonna probably eat all
those blueberries and my yogurt and I'm
sure they'll have something at the craft
table to gnosh on as well
elderflower yogurt
slaps
it says transporting you to a Nordic
mid-summer
I like that idea unless you've watched
the horror film mid-summer
and that is not my idea of a good time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh and as I was getting ready I also had
a little fruit plate and some kind of
egg wrap from The Craft on set
I'm really
I'm really tired
this sounds good
goat cheese
oh no
[Music]
foreign
I have never been so tired and hungry at
the same time but like so tired that I'm
not really hungry because I feel
nauseous I think I'm just thirsty
let me tell you that was a very long day
it was like a long time to be on and
super energetic
oh
when you've been up since 3am
that burns
that also feels good I just found a poke
Bowl place on the way home it was like
the first place I saw I was like yes
I'll take all the things I got to choose
three proteins I chose the most random
things of life
spicy chicken salmon and shrimp
I don't know what I'm doing here but
going down because
it's
so
y sauce for the ricey rice
that's on your crushing combo if I ever
did see what
that was so spicy that was so spicy
and um like I I was
snot coming down my my nose my ear my
eyes ears everything this leaking
the mucus Queen is yours
but it felt good and I enjoyed it and I
do like a little bit of
heat pain if you know what I'm saying
but I'm gonna go for a little walk call
my hubby see what's going on how the day
went and
I'll catch you in the morning
pray
for
pray for a better sleep for me guys
morning lovelies so last night's sleep
was definitely a lot better so basically
I woke up again at 3 12 on the dot which
is the exact same time that I woke up
the night before and I never got back to
sleep so I was kind of like a bit of a
freak out woman because that actually
often happens to me where a bad night's
sleep will imprint really hard on my
brain and then I will end up waking up
the exact same time for a couple nights
until I basically just like burn out so
I was like
no I'm so tired and uh I tried to calm
myself down took a few little
spritzy spritzes of melatonin which is
what my my doctor suggested
and I fell back asleep
so I woke up at 5 30 which is a great
accomplishment for me
um and now I'm on the hunt I'm on the
prowl for some coffee but it's like
legit every coffee shop I pass by
they're not open for like another half
hour 45 minutes and I'm like
where are my early birds at where am I
insomniacs at I need coffee so
I'm hoping when I get the coffee that my
voice works itself out and it just kind
of like gives a little warm up la la la
la la la la
I'll do some exercises before I head on
over I'm sure my hotel neighbors will
love me anyway gotta pay attention here
folks because I think I see
the Green Angel who would call her
Starbucks are they open
now we start the day
[Music]
so that took a little longer than I
expected but it looks so good so I'm
just gonna like wolf down the avocado
toast and eggs right now and then I've
also got another one of these like
little yogurt cups and some fruit that
I'll take with me to the shoot and
finish it while I'm getting my hair did
lemonade
[Music]
look how cute these glasses are they are
a vibe
all right lunch is a Greek salad
I've got some barbecue chicken here I'm
gonna throw on top love these chili
pistachios they're so good and some
Pirates Booty which I only ever get on
down here in the state so I'm really
excited about that
also there's like a whole Red Onion in
my salad which I very promptly removed
because nasty no
foreign
[Music]
I very quickly just took all my makeup
off as it was feeling very heavy
um and I'm going to make a beeline to
Trader Joe's because all Canadians are
obsessed with Trader Joe's and I'm gonna
try to pick up a few things to make like
a snackable dinner for myself
because why not when in New York
[Music]
of course I just walked 15 minutes in
the wrong effing Direction
in the heat oh my God
I've never been so excited
to put my feet up okay so my dinner
options were admittedly kind of limited
because I don't have a microwave here
and I don't have any way to cook
anything so we're having a snackable
dinner and I'm okay with that I already
had a salad today but this was my option
for veg and I've got some protein in
here with some chicken
I love the freeze-dried berries and I
got some of their skir yogurt so we'll
have that together
this intrigued me hello so very excited
at that okay so clearly there's a peanut
butter theme I do love peanut butter and
caramel and popcorn yum and you guys
know how I feel about everything
everything but the bagel so I had to
grab those too and I think the is where
your girl is gonna sign off New York
it's been a pleasure
[Music]
but they
when they say this is the city that
never sleeps because oh my gosh I am
tired my legs are tired my feet are
tired my body is tired my throat is
tired my voice is tired my eyes are
tired but I had like such a blast and I
am so excited to share with you guys
what I was even here for so if you like
this little vloggy Vlog be sure to give
me the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with other kind of Vlog ideas that
you want to see me do subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]